went wrong long time ago I was a man in
space
you bros remember and this [ __ ] UFO
kept shooting me it [ __ ] what an [ __ ]
am i right what do I do now it says
press s ok I will place a black we
discovered smarmy knees on all fell plan
on by a brain Josh whoa holy [ __ ] no one
told me I had a jet pack let's keep
landing ships and killing immigrants
this game sends a great message to the
people of yet what yeah we're just gonna
go off in space now [ __ ] this alright
twelve seconds later I am very low on
jet pack fuel I'm probably gonna
probably gonna die here
all right well let's land on this
[ __ ] sorry guys this is my part
you'll just suck a big fat [ __ ]
tentacle dick I'm a boss you know it
looks you know I got a plan I kind of
play it's kind of planet is bundage err
then let's use super nova boss